we have fewer democracies in the world
today than we did 15 years ago
fewer not more
fewer all right people it is January
19th 2024 I'm Dave Ruben this is the
Ruben report and do not worry you are
not having any sort of medical emergency
if your screen is feeling a little weird
right now uh first off that was an AI
generated Joe Biden as our called open
and yes I am sitting a little lower than
normal my desk is not here uh because uh
the set that we use for the in-person
interviews was just used I just had CIA
former CIA agent uh Mike Baker on the
show we just did an hour all about
foreign policy and the agencies and a
whole bunch more I really really really
enjoyed it it was nice to get away from
a little bit of the racehorse politics
this week and just talking about
primaries and all that that uh clip one
of that will be up on Monday anyway we
didn't have time to swap over the set so
you're going to have to deal with Dave
just a little lower to the ground today
if you can bear with me I promise you I
will bring it for the next 45 minutes or
so uh the theme today is as we were
talking about earlier in the week uh
this world economic forum is happening
in Davos this is where the globalists
and the central planners decide how you
should live your life as they eat the
wagu and fly their private planes uh but
iier mle the new president of Argentina
showed up and basically told the
Communists to go shove it it was pretty
beautiful so we're going to show you two
clips of that and then jump into a Ruben
report. locals.com Community Q&A so
let's just do it Javier M got on a
commercial flight that's right he's
probably the only guy in all of Davos
that did not fly private got on a
commercial flight from buenos Ires went
all the way over to Davos and he laid
down some truth to the people that want
you to eat
bugs good afternoon thank you very
much today I am present to inform you
that the Western world is facing a
significant
threat it is in danger because those who
are supposed to defend the values of the
western world are coopted by a world viw
that inevitably leads to socialism and
consequently to poverty and economic
deprivation unfortunately in recent
decades motivated by some
well-intentioned desires to help others
and others by the desire to belong to a
privileged cast the main leaders of the
western world have abandon the model of
freedom for different versions of what
we call
collectivism
we are here to tell you that
collectivist experiments are never the
solution to the problems that afflict
the citizens of the world but rather
they are their
cause trust me there is no one better
than us argentines to provide testimony
on these two issues okay he went on and
on we're going to show you one more clip
of that but like I feel like somebody
over there at the WF was like uh uh
clouse who invited this guy he's
basically saying everything that's the
complete reverse
of the collectivist worldview of the
elites above the peons worldview that we
promote in Davos every year and then we
send our agents out to become
politicians and media members and run
institutions in all of these countries
like that guy is poking a big hole in
the whole freaking thing couple
brilliant things about there so he's
talking about the values of the West and
the values of the west of course are
based in the individual that it is you
first our governments are supposed to
protect our rights not give us rights
right you have a choice in this world to
go out and do something not just wait
for the crumbs from the people above you
right and that is completely counter to
the wef message it's completely counter
to what we are now seeing as socialism
and communism or Marxism it doesn't even
matter what you want to call it at this
point as it creeps through all of these
Western governments um and then I I like
the line where he talked about that it's
this combination really of well-meaning
people of course you know where the road
to hell with the well-meaning people and
on the road to Hell there's some
connection there right that's where it
ends up uh it's the well-meaning people
slash what did he say the privileged
class so there at the WF you've got the
privileged class and they are telling
you how to live and then you get the
well-meaning people these progressives
these college Progressive kids and they
mean well but the road to hell is paved
with good intentions so the privileged
class uses them and then that explains
why a bunch of college kids are out
there rallying for things that they know
nothing about and constantly complaining
while they live in the freest most
prosperous Societies in the history of
the world uh let's just go on a little
bit more Javier Malay on socialism and
authoritarianism now if free market
capitalism and economic freedom have
been remarkable instruments to eradicate
poverty globally and we are presently
experiencing the most favorable period
in human history it is worth inquiring
why I assert that the West is in
jeopardy
I argue that the West is endangered as
in countries defending free market
private property and other institutions
of
libertarianism sectors of the political
and economic establishment due to errors
in their theoretical framework and
ambition for power undermine
libertarianism opening doors to
socialism and potentially condemning us
to Poverty misery and
stagnation because it should never be
observed that socialism is always and
everywhere impoverishing failed in all
countries where
attempted it was a failure economically
it was a failure socially it was a
failure culturally and it also killed
more than a 100 million human beings you
really need to understand this guy
showing up there is it's so powerful
because first off again how the hell did
he get the invite I mean I know they
have to pretend that they're not as evil
as they are but he gets the invite he
shows up he tells them everything that
they don't want to hear to the point
that you may remember yesterday we
played you a video of klous Schwab just
the day before at the world economic
Forum basically saying that their whole
mission their whole purpose is to crush
and destroy the ideas of libertarianism
that too many people think for
themselves and don't want to Outsource
all of their autonomy and that's a
problem for the world economic Forum so
he comes there shows a different
argument I don't know that he wakes up
anyone in that room right they are the
the privileged class they are the Elite
they've set out their agenda and they do
it with all the weirdo artists that show
up there and everything else uh but the
more that anyone watching that WF
conference can get some of the good
ideas too for anyone that's watching it
going boy those collectivists sure are
making sense and then you hear this guy
and you go well that that actually did
make sense too that that is pretty damn
good so who would have thought that the
guy really on the Forefront of leading
the world hopefully out of collectivism
and socialism would have been the the
president of Argentina with that crazy
hair who it's just absolutely absolutely
incredible let's talk about the wellness
company real quick and then we'll get
into a community Q&A guys recent
clusters of respiratory illnesses in
northern China alongside outbreaks of
what's being referred to as white lung
syndrome in the US are scattered across
headlines right now drawing attention to
the importance of being prepared for
medical emergencies with close to 90% of
pharmac Pharmaceuticals in the US being
produced outside the US what happens
when the next Global crisis strikes
countries clamp down on exports they
stockpile the price of drugs rise in the
pharmacy shelves in America become empty
this is already starting to happen
actually so what's the solution here
well you guys have heard me talk about
the wellness company before but when
we're staring down the barrel of Times
Like These their medical emergency kit
is a must have the wellness company is
home to Dr Peter McCulla Dr Drew Pinsky
and truth-telling doctors who are rooted
in their commitment to building a
parallel Health Care system and
empowering you to take control of your
health in a time when over 40% of
Americans say they would avoid a doctor
or Hospital unless it was a catastrophic
situation the wellness company's medical
emergency kit provides a solution this
handy little kit includes eight
potentially life-saving medications for
you to keep on hand along with a guide
book for safe use the medical emergency
kit includes emergency antibiotics
antivirals antiparasitics like
amoxicillin zpac and Ivermectin to help
keep you and your family safe in the
face of natural disasters supply chain
shortages or medical emergencies like
white longer covid go to tww
c.in and grab your medical emergency kit
right now that's
twc.gov out of communist California
congratulations but I got to be honest
our current neighborhood and home have
made our status quo rather comfortable
and I'm nervous about silly things like
will the shower have water pressure the
way I like it will the transition from a
gas stove to electric stove drive me
bonkers are are there any Creature
Comforts you missed from your home in LA
or were there any unexpected things in
Florida that took some getting used to
other than iguanas enjoying your pool
well it's not the iguanas in my pool
that's a problem it's that Clyde is
constantly mauling iguanas and I have to
clean up blood and I find wagging tails
of iguanas like Tails still alive but
the Iguana is gone that aside um well
actually you bring up one of one of my
few big ones so the area that I happen
to live in the suburbs of Miami we did
not have natural they they weren't
hooked up for natural gas so we got here
and we had an electric stove and as you
guys know we're we're both quite good
chefs DAV it's particularly good and you
know generally chefs don't want to cook
on electric or induction stoves uh so we
had propane tanks put in and we had to
get new stoves and it was pain in the
butt with the kitchen and had to move
things around um but yes so if you are
leaving your electric stove sorry if
you're leaving your gas stove where you
can control that fire so beautifully and
you're moving to Electric for the first
time in your life like you may want to
look into doing propane that's one thing
um you know getting I lived in La which
is which when La was right was it was
the high end of everything so you could
get you'd go to the perfect Salon you'd
go everything was kind of the you could
find all the best doctors the best
dentists all that it's been a little
more of a challenge here but you know
all the tradeoffs for the freedom and
that the government is not in your way
it's actually just kind of protecting
you sort of some of that jaob stuff it
is all a good trade-off you're going to
save some money on taxes and I know it's
never it's never easy to move you know I
when I talk about this stuff and people
Everyone always responds they say but
you know my parents live here I have
this commitment my family's here my kids
in school I'm never saying it's easy you
just have to ultimately decide what is
best for you but if you guys have
finally decided to make the move uh I
think you're going to love it here and I
look forward to finding out a little bit
more about the journey uh Cel says howdy
Dave I was wondering if Trump is a shoe
in for the Republican nominee I was
wondering why Dan santis would stay in
it could it be that the remainder of
this run is actually preparation for
2028 well first off I I don't know that
he's a Shuan but as I keep saying he's
the presumptive nominee at this point
and in that we know the santis is not
going to do well in New Hampshire he
never was going to do well in New
Hampshire the polls have it's basically
Nikki and Trump at 4040 the santis at
literally like four then there's Nevada
which that's kind of trump country maybe
the santaa is okay there but it's a
small state and then and then of course
South Carolina is the big one before
super Tuesday but Nikki was the governor
there and Trump is most likely going to
win that um what I would want from
disantis right now is if he believes
that Trump is not a shuing then you got
to just lay out the plan just lay out
the plan I I'll put the video up and a
gajillion people will put the video up I
don't even need to comment here's the
plan and then and then I could kind of
go with it a little bit more but
unfortunately I haven't heard that so my
sense is that this thing it is going to
be Trump uh as I've said on the show the
last couple days look Trump especially
preco Trump was a good president if you
put a aside the side sh and I know
that's hard for people and you put aside
the Mean Tweets and whatever and I and
again I do want Trump to level up and
that's what I'm going to really work on
over the next year not just not just
bowing but but actually trying to push
for some of the things and I think that
that is something that could make him
better um if you if you look back though
to those those first two years the
economy was chugging along uh the Middle
East was in peace we had peace deals
more peace deals were on the way lowest
all time black unemployment lowest all
time Latino unemployment like I get it
the left was apoplectic the media was
going crazy Nazis but like in reality it
was going pretty good so I think he it
looks like he's the presumptive nominee
and and if I'm wrong and I know a lot of
the team Des santis people watch this
like literally on the team um let me
know so we so we can talk about it
obviously uh Jenny says hey Dave how
much has running your own business
changed your political world viiew I
understand you were always out there as
an entrepreneur in a way trying to make
it as a standup Etc but it seems that
owning a business that employs other
people would make a pretty big impact on
how a person sees this world you know I
used to talk about this a little bit
more a couple years ago but it was
hugely impactful to me so when I started
uh the production company that now runs
the Ruben report and then ultimately you
know we started a tech company that
created locals it was really just about
creating the Ruben report Community
First and then that worked so we were
like let's spin this off to other people
that's where the idea locals came locals
ultimately merged with Rumble Etc but
when I started the production company
and then we started hiring people and we
we've built several Studios now I don't
even want to think back to how many
studios we've built and then you run
into issues with regulations and you
start looking at taxes and you're paying
payroll tax and you hire this person and
all these things I was also in the same
process now we're talking you know like
six seven years ago I was in the same
process of talking to a lot of
libertarian economists I was thinking
about taxes a little bit differently and
all that so what was happening was I was
kind of learning the intellectual side
of these things and putting them into
practice in my life at the exact same
time which was pretty beautiful and then
you know if I flash forward now to just
these last two years we move here to
Florida where I obviously Save A Lot on
income tax but as you know that was not
why I moved here um but all my employees
save on income tax that's more money
they can do with whatever whatever they
want to do with um the to build things
here and do things at my house there's
less regulation there's less red tape
like all that kind of stuff so I would
say all of my learning of again to get
it to that jav heray thing like the
libertarian side of things that you
should do things for yourself and then
you'll start doing things for your
community and then we'll go up this way
um it was completely in line with what I
was learning on the show so it worked
out nicely I guess uh politically
homeless mama that's a good name says so
many Republicans will endorse Trump just
to defeat Biden and many Biden voters
will vote Biden just to defeat Trump
it's lose lose how is vote blue no
matter who uh that any different than
you don't have to be a republican but
you can't be a Democrat that's something
I say often obviously what is the option
for reasonable people in the middle for
the first time in my adult life I can't
even choose the lesser of two evils and
hold my nose to vote it's disheartening
and demoralizing um I really appreciate
that comment and it's partly why again
if Trump is the nominee that my my
intentions will be to push him to be a
little bit better um and I know nobody
really it seems like nobody can really
affect him but I think if enough of us
talk about the issues like not from
we're trying to destroy you side but
like oh there's there's ways we can do
things a little bit different a little
bit better maybe you can have some
better people around you Etc like maybe
they can move him a little bit but I
completely hear you there are a huge
amount of people that and this was my
fears with Trump becoming the nominee if
Dan santis was the nominee he might be
hated by the media and people can say he
don't say gay and he's scary and he took
out Mickey Mouse and all that stuff but
there isn't the abject level of bananas
Insanity related to him and because
there is related to Trump we know that
Millions it's it's literally millions of
people that would not have voted last
time on the left on the Democrat side
are going to vote because they're going
to vote anti-trump that's just real that
is just a real thing they have created
this idea that he's orange Hitler and
it's going to cause people who otherwise
wouldn't have voted or would have been
apathetic or might have voted third
party to to vote Biden or whoever the de
Democrat nominee is so that that's an
issue um my argument when I always say
uh that you don't have to be a
republican but you can't be a Democrat
is the Democrat part is completely
insane I'm not telling you the Republic
Republican part is that great it's good
here in Florida but the national
Republican party they they mostly kind
of suck and partly another reason why I
don't want every I don't want to be in a
party that everybody bows to the dear
leader so again that's that's sort of
why I I don't consider myself a kind of
national uh Republican but it's also why
several times on the show this week we
played clips from RFK he's an
independent Kennedy name can he get on
these ballots maybe that's a little more
in line with your views I suspect it
probably is um you just have to make
whatever decision is best for you but
yes I think you quite well summed up
what most people are feeling right now
like if this thing ends up as Trump and
Biden doesn't doesn't matter if you like
one more than the other or anything else
it's just like that's we all know this
is not what the country deserves right
now like this or no no no we might
deserve it because we're the people but
it's not the thing that is going to get
us out of the much grander problem and
it's just going to add more to that and
I think that in and of itself is a
spiritual problem more than a political
problem Mantra says after an extensive
and beloved bourbon Discovery I'm
interested in exploring tequila and I've
started a small collection while I enjoy
sipping I'm not finding a lot of depth
and variety of flavor across different
sources can you give me a brief tutorial
on the fundamentals of this liquor and
how best to enjoy it all right the very
simple version of tequila you've got
your Blancos that's the very it's unaged
right so it's the agave plant but it's
not aged it's straight up it's clear
that's what they're making margaritas
out of that's what they're making um uh
what is it with grapefruit juice uh pal
Paloma sorry um that's like the cocktail
drink right so generally I don't you
know it's funny I don't find just
drinking a a Blanco tequila like
straight up around the Rocks I don't
find it that enjoyable when we've been
in Mexico talking to Tequila Somalia a
lot of them really do like it because
that's where you're getting like the
most pure pure flavor because it hasn't
been aged in in CS and casks and all
that um but that's generally most people
don't do that just drink like straight
up Blanco tequila then there's uh
Reposado which is aged for 3 months uh
sometimes in Bourbon barrels different
kinds of barrels and then there's which
I think is aged 6 to 9 months if I'm not
mistaken and then there's uh extrao
which can be aged over 9 months which
you're going to get a much like richer
flavor darker color all of that I like I
don't like just straight up uh with no
ice I I like it on one big rock I would
say invest a couple bucks you can get
beautiful uh circular uh ice cubes one
rock nice glass little tequila swirl it
around I would say so you want richer
flavor it sounds like like so go to you
could probably skip reposados I actually
usually like reposados cuz it's warmer
here so I like something that's like a
little like lighter um but you could
probably go right to an aose or even uh
extra an aose and um trying to think I
don't want to give you a brand because
we're working on our tequila and I don't
have like an extra Neo brand because
it's not really my thing um just keep
tasting them it'll work itself
out drink tequila goodbye okay cool mom
says the racist label is still going
strong I want to be able to change the
minds of liberals around me in New
Mexico I believe your viewers myself
included see the left as racists based
on the narratives around black people
being able to get an ID blacks getting
abortions at higher rates the welfare
system and saav enslaving blacks Etc are
there legitimate instances where it can
be argued that Republicans make
inherently racist
policies well first off I would say you
do know that the Republican party was
founded in with the very idea of
eliminating racism that was the split
between the wigs and the Republicans uh
but putting that aside at the moment
like right now could there have been
policies over the years southern
strategy things of that nature could
there have been policies over the years
that the Republicans instituted that
were inherently
racist I'm open to anyone in this room
throwing me one but generally the
policies that were race-based in America
came from the Democrats and the things
that have harmed the black family the
most like the welfare state and
encouraging black women it was generally
black women you could have been a poor
white woman too but generally black
women to have as many kids as possible
get those kids on the Dole uh things
like um you know keeping rent down so St
rent stabilized departments things of
this nature it kind of sounds right but
then
eventually if you have certain people in
a building paying market share so
they're paying what the apartment's
actually worth and then someone down the
hall is paying some rent subsidized
thing because of their largely because
of the color of their skin and they're
getting money from the government and
EBT cards and everything else they never
want to get out of that cycle of poverty
that's not because they're Lazy by the
nature of the color of their skin what
it is is because if the government
starts handing you something and you're
like boy I don't really work and the
government gives me I don't know a th000
bucks a month and my rent in this place
is only 200 bucks that schmuck down the
hall his rent's 4,000 bucks like why
would I ever get off the government doll
because then I'd have to leave this
apartment I'd have to move to a
different burrow Etc Etc so the Democrat
policies while well-intentioned for the
most part right and you could argue I
suppose the same argue that Javier
Malayan uh said that I think you could
probably argue that the the elite layer
of the Democrats many years ago realized
this was a great way to kind of crush
this community and keep them voting
Democrat give them crumbs and they'll
keep coming back and then there were I
would say well-meaning
people that thought oh if we just give
these people something they'll be able
to catch up and it's just not how human
nature works Uh Kevin says why does so
many Americans of Jewish descent support
the left especially now that the left
has shown itself to be anti-israel well
I do think that is changing but the the
real answer to your question I think
we've talked about this a couple times
before uh is that Jews as a minority
understand what it is like to be a
minority so they have largely been at
the Forefront of movements for equality
so if you look at the pictures any of
the pictures you can Google them right
now of Dr Martin Luther King marching
with people arm in- arm a good
percentage of the people that he was
marching with marching uh with were
Jewish people because they were
understanding of the plight of them to
get to equality right it was the country
clubs that first didn't want the Jews
and then also didn't want the black
people so as Jews be got equal rights
then ultimately black people got equal
rights too the March towards equality is
always a just cause I think what
happened unfortunately was once the
March towards equality got to equality
people people just did not know how to
recalibrate and unfortunately that left
the left which as Jordan Peterson often
talks about when does the left go too
far the left never knows when it goes
too far so a series of people who I
think were in it for the right reasons
and that gets you to that good
intentions thing they just kind of went
off the deep end I am very happy to say
that in the last uh three plus months
since October 7th I've seen an awful lot
of Jews who suddenly even some in my own
family and friends people that stopped
talking to me years ago like suddenly
like Dave oh maybe I kind of do get it
about identity politics and maybe there
was something wrong with the woke thing
and oh I guess calling for genocide at
Harvard's probably not great and you
know trying to you know endlessly all
day long destroy the one Jewish State
when there are dozens of Christian
majority countries and dozens of Muslim
majority countries like maybe there is a
little bit of a problem here but as you
guys know the the the left likes their
minorities
oppressed and Jews by becoming
successful we're not an oppressed
minority this goes largely for most
Asian communities this goes largely for
Indians as well talking about Indians
from India and once you don't fit into
that calculator once you don't fit into
that thing anymore you're going to be
pushed out on the other side it's just
uh it's as simple as that uh let's see
uh Terry says after Larry Elder lost in
the recall race why didn't he run in the
next gubernatorial race he could have
had momentum and made a difference uh so
for those of you that uh don't remember
so Larry ran
as Republican in the recall election so
first there was a recall of Gavin Nome
and it was very complex I think two
million people signed the recall you had
to hand sign it they made it so hard
because it was the middle of covid so
you couldn't do anything they're telling
us to do everything online but the
recall thing you had to sign in person I
remember exactly where I signed it I was
I used somebody on their back they let
me sign it and you could if your if your
signature touched the line above or
below it would be it would be eliminated
and not counted they made it really
complex to do but anyway the the recall
went forward and then Larry got can we
check how many uh votes Larry Elder got
I think it was about 2.5 million votes
if I'm not mistaken uh he did lose to
Gavin Nome and then they subsequently
last year had another election I think
he just decided hey I gave it a shot uh
this is a one-party State he's staying
there and fighting he is he is from
South Central wait is he from South
Central originally I think from South
Central LA uh parents from Los Angel
like he's a Los Angelino he is fighting
for California and I I fully respect
that like obviously I respect it it was
a good worthwhile fight that that we did
and I'm glad that I was part of it um
let's see I'm getting the numbers on he
got 3.5 million votes so think about 3.5
million people which is 28% voted for
Larry Elder in the recall obviously it
wasn't enough to Dethrone Gavin Newsome
unfortunately but in essence I think he
felt that that was his that was his
chance he did I think I can say this
Larry don't be pissed if I'm not
supposed to say this the night after the
recall failed we had Larry and his uh
his girlfriend come over girlfriend
they've been together for years but uh
they came over for dinner and he told me
that he was going to run for president
that night and I was like are you nuts
and and he actually did it so I just
love him he's just great uh we can save
America 2024 says Dave and the Ruben
Clan you guys have a unified passionate
and loyal Community here however like
all families we don't always agree in
this business you need to have a very
thick skin how do you deal with mean
rude and angry comments are there mean
rude and angry comments in there I very
rarely see them I I I don't see them
that often in the locals community so I
would say if you're seeing them um well
first off if people are being like
absolutely insane I think in the Years
all the years that we've had the locals
Community I think we've banned one
person and my policy I don't even
remember exactly it was somebody that
just would not stop posting and fighting
with everybody we asked them to be
respectful they wouldn't do it and of
course the locals policy was we're not
Banning you off the platform you're
allowed to be in anyone else's Community
I just didn't want you in my community
like you know sort of like I don't
invite everybody into my house to say
whatever the hell they want but you can
say what you want outside um I honestly
haven't seen too much of that at all I
think usually people are I know there
can be some heated stuff and I think
probably in the last 10 days or so as
the as the Trump to santis thing started
burning hot but I'll I'll keep an eye on
that and I would say just don't take it
too much to heart we're you know we're
all we're all keyboard Warriors we all
say things that way that we would never
say this way and uh yeah just you close
the app every now and again if it's
getting to you uh Alise says in your
heart of hearts do you think Trump can
be significantly better as a politician
than he has been since
2020 I don't know I don't know but
that's why I've tried to say the things
that I've said in this last week about
him being a little bit better like like
if you really think about it what are
the chances that a 77y old man having
gone through what he's going through
through with the court cases now the
craziness with the media all of that
stuff like did he learn lessons and
change in any way and if he changed in
any way how would the people who love
him even react to that let's say he got
a little bit softer and started seeming
a little more thoughtful or whatever it
is that anyone might want out of him
like would that be would he view that as
a sign of weakness would the would the
other side view that as a sign of
weakness so my guess my ultimate guess
is you get your going to get exactly the
same thing out of him but maybe maybe
and again this is where I'm going to
keep pushing him maybe if he can
surround himself with a few better
people but but again he has a long track
record of taking people out that he
brought in so you don't know who's going
to want to work for him but maybe we can
do a little bit on the margins with him
and if we can do that and if they if
they don't unleash uh disease X or
whatever then it will probably be better
than the look at the end of the day if
if a Trump Administration took over
tomorrow would it be better or worse
than what's happening right now well
there's every reason to think they would
at least do something about the border
right they would probably lower taxes a
little bit that they would do something
there um I think there would be more
reason to think that Hamas might be like
all right we better uh return some of
those those hostages especially the
American ones because who knows what
that crazy orange guy is going to do
Putin might feel a little bit like uh oh
we can't walk all over the American
anymore so even if he's just still as
nutty as ever and everything else I
still think it's a little bit better
than having a guy who's clearly not in
charge and also who has dementia and you
know a woman that really seems like she
didn't graduate second grade behind him
Amy Says in your opinion what band and
also which solo artist is the most
overrated I am sure I'm going to get a
lot of for this but I don't like
the Beatles I like the Beatles I've
never liked the Beatles it's just noisy
it's a lot of sounds at once I don't
I just don't I bet the Beatles never
were played in my house you've all been
here for many parties have you ever
heard the Beatles here never there will
be no Beatles at my house Conor's
freaking out he's about to cut the feed
um so and what solo artist is
overrated uh I don't like that Kanye
West not a fan not a I don't like the uh
I don't like that kind of
music or the ha in the Jew thing uh
Rosie says Dave regarding your show
yesterday and communicating with Trump
about refraining from his old
Shenanigans and holding accountable to
integrity and truth-telling do you plan
to go through Don Jr to do this how do
we communicate with Trump so he gets the
message I was in the disantis camp but
want to see Trump successful and that is
the way the majority is going thanks
well first of I just want to say that I
love the fact that uh that the audience
of this show is all over the place right
like when I look at the comments
especially in locals but on Rumble and
YouTube like my audience is everywhere
there are Trump people there are
DeSantis people there are lefties that
are just waking up we've got a whole
bunch of them right now because of
October 7th who I talked about who are
kind of on the way the audience is all
over the place and again that's why I
can only just tell you what I think and
you'll either agree or disagree and and
hopefully at least be entertained a
little so you come back like that that's
my what I believe my job is right and my
purpose in all of this um as for how to
get to Trump I mean I think there's a
couple ways one just do the show and the
more people watch like Trump is a man of
media and you know if I say some good
ideas that maybe get repeated on some
other shows and then things start kind
of percolating up the zeit guys maybe
that gets to him um I I actually haven't
reached out to D JR this week yet I will
I didn't want to text him like the day
after and be like okay how you doing man
like looks like your your dad's gonna
get it um like that just seemed kind of
silly to me but I'll reach out to him in
a day or two or I'll reach out to Ivanka
and uh I I sense that Junior would have
well no for sure Junior has more
connection on the political side I think
in terms of influencing his dad um so
yeah I would talk to him may you know
maybe maybe maybe I'll see Trump like I
I just don't know but I think there's
many ways to skin a cat uh toway says
with so many disaffected liberals now
being pushed to the right there's a
theme today what are some of the things
you believe traditional conservatives
and Common Sense liberals need to focus
on to have any hope of coming together
to Wi in November and what topics should
they avoid at all costs well I'll do the
the latter part first I mean I think the
main one that everyone should just kind
of if you can agree to disagree on is
abortion there was no way that that the
liberal from Cali who's for seven month
abortions or not even seven months for
20 week abortions or 15 we abortions was
ever going to agree with Rona Sant six
week abortions so if you're a pure
prolifer and you see someone waking up
on the other side and suddenly they're
like you know the gun gun thing I guess
I was wrong on that and I guess I guess
policing is good and I'm starting to see
that education's kind of screwy and I
guess you shouldn't chop off kids dicks
and there's a couple other things well
you might want to welcome these people
over but if you start going going into
abortion with them it's off the table
I've seen that happen a good jillion
times it's particularly with women but
I've seen that happen a million times
you don't have to agree on abortion you
don't but I think that's the one you
just have to Shell I would say the
things that you can largely agree on uh
are just have them turn there are
reasons that they're waking up there are
reasons that I talk about that group of
people all the time and it's not just
because I was one of them it's just
obvious that that if you look at all of
the types of people that could vote one
way or another that could shift parties
the disaffected liberal who's just like
this Democrat Party has gone freaking
bananas those are the people to get now
there's probably a version of that on
the other side and it might be
percolating right now there's probably
the type of Republican who's just like
I've just freaking had it with Trump
maybe I voted for him last time I can't
do it again I'm seeing that I mean I'm
definitely seeing some of that I don't
think that's as many people as as maybe
could go in the other direction um so I
think you just have to you just have to
show them it's like well it's it's not
racist to want school choice or be
involved in what your kid learns it's
not racist to be against affirmative
action and want people to be judged by
the content of the character like if
you've watched this show long enough you
know enough of those arguments and I I
would say more than anything else you
could take the classically liberal
position of being willing to agree to
disagree uh but do not take the position
of putting tolerance at the the most
important piece of it where you will
then allow the intolerant people into
your home Florida and Chuck says since
the Democrats blow and the Republicans
suck you guys know where I got that from
by the way you know I feel like Connor
would know she both blows and sucks you
don't know where I got that no that's
Space Balls the giant maid the giant
maid in Space Balls she's gone from blow
to suck uh since the Democrats blow and
the Republicans suck if Trump does get
reelected do you see swamp creatures
like McConnell will try to side with the
Democrats to obfuscate and block Trump
from front from trying to turn the
country around yes yes I do I do Mitch
McConnell is 8,000 years old he has been
in DC for
6572 years the man is is wedded to that
more than he is wedded to America I
don't talk about Mitch McConnell that
often I don't even know how many times
I've I've mentioned him on the show
occasionally his brain shuts off and
we've shown you those clips but like the
type of people that have just been there
forever when people talk about the Deep
State and I don't mean it in a
conspiracy sense but the the the
Machinery that's in Washington that just
exists over time time over time
Administration over Administration
doesn't matter if it's democrat or
republican but that seems to be the
thing they want to protect Trump seems
to be the threat to that sort sort of
thing so I could absolutely see if Trump
came in there and and I'm sure there are
stories about this I have no doubt there
are stories about this when Trump came
in the first time McConnell is going
well hey I I like the operation that we
kind of have going here now I'm
Republican so I'm a little more one way
than than these crazy people over here
but I don't want to blow the whole thing
apart and by the way I don't know that
we have to blow the whole thing apart
there are ways you can change things on
the margins you know you blow the whole
thing apart you might find out that boy
what you had was actually pretty good
you didn't you did not realize it you
know what why don't you guys comment
below not only in locals locals is where
I go for all my comments and you guys
actually enlighten me on things often
more than than plenty of the other
pundits do but comment below on rumble
on YouTube Etc we'll have the team jump
in we'll look around and we'll see how
uh we can keep shaping things going
forward I'm going to always tell you how
I see it but it's nice to know that with
a wide audience that you guys are seeing
things a little bit differently uh if
you want to join us and get a question
in on our next Q&A Ruben report.
locals.com reminder we've got a new X
Twitter account for the clips of the
show it's Ruben report show uh and if
you did not see our show yesterday it is
my Iowa recap and my primary recap with
my co-host Megan Kelly part one of my
interview that I just did which again is
why I'm sitting a little lower than
usual because we had to rearrange the
studio with Mike Baker is up on uh
Monday that's all I have to say there's
no postgame show today because I'm
actually in New York I'm on Gutfeld
tonight okay goodbye and I appreciate
the world economic Forum providing me
the opportunity to be on this stage and
say you CLA Schwab and you New World
Auto we the people were born free we
will stay free and you and all of your
globalist friends including everyone in
this room can go
yourself